[Music]  I'm gonna tell you a story about a ghost  a werewolf and a pretty shitty pizza  place it all started when the werewolf  came back to town  a pizza delivery boy was murdered while  making a routine delivery Kingfisher  Chronicle can ask you a few questions  buying the wolf you'll find look killer  tonight ghost involvement the killing of  Sean hammerschmidt  looks like I'm going on a wolf hunt  tonight  what the [ __ ] does that have to do with  pizza your pizza place is a gateway to  help  wait so you tell me my pizza place is  built on a gateway to hell I've been  saying that what never come down does  that thing you should have ended a long  time ago  [Music]  oh [ __ ] god damn what's wrong with you  [Music]